-The number-two House
Republican refused to say
that the 2020 election was
not stolen from Donald Trump,
while the Biden administration
blocked an attempt by Trump
to withhold documents related
to the investigation
of the January 6th
insurrection at the Capitol.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
There's a lot
going on right now,
from the GOP's ongoing attempts
to dismantle democracy
to centrist Democrats holding up
President Biden's agenda
to Bernie Sanders
holding press conferences
in a leather chair,
therapist-style.
"How will we pay for it?
Oh! What a great question.
That is a new one!
I've never heard
that one before.
I'm gonna write you a note
that says, 'Tax the rich,'
and a prescription
for some ginkgo biloba."
[ Laughter ]
But here's a moment
from last week
that pretty much sums
up my feelings
about the current state
of our politics.
Biden was asked about
a short-term deal
to avert economic catastrophe
and raise the debt ceiling.
In response,
he crossed his fingers,
although, at first,
I thought he was going
for a very different
hand gesture.
[ Laughter ]
It really does encapsulate
where we're at politically,
that every response
is a coin flip
between "hoping for the best"
and "[bleep] off!"
[ Laughter ]
I definitely thought Biden
was going full bird there,
mostly because of his technique.
Yes, his fingers were crossed,
but he brought it up like he was
cranking with the other hand.
[ Laughter ]
This was the risk we took
when we elected
President Finger Guns.
Those things
are deadly weapons.
They make him run it
through the metal detector
when he comes to work
every morning.
With Trump,
I was always worried
he was going to say the wrong
thing to a world leader,
but with Biden,
I'm afraid a hand gesture
is going to get away from him.
"Bad news --
The President tried to do
a 'I see you'
to the Sultan of Brunei,
and instead he slipped
and he Three Stooged him."
"What?!"
[ Laughter ]
"Why didn't the Sultan
do a block hand?"
"I guess they don't
have the Stooges there."
[ Laughter ]
During the time you were gone,
we did a lot of
"MASH" references,
a "Star Trek Next Generation,"
but obviously now
human beings are here.
We had to freshen it up
with the Stooges.
[ Laughter ]
While Biden was desperately
trying to convince Republicans
to do the bare minimum to avert
potential economic catastrophe
over the debt ceiling,
he was also refusing
an attempt by his predecessor
to shield documents from
a congressional investigation
into the insurrection
on January 6th.
-NBC News first to report
earlier today
that the Biden White House
has decided, in fact,
not to block the release
of documents related to Trump,
his presidency,
and the insurrection.
The move sets up a legal
and potentially lengthy showdown
between two presidents,
current and former,
over the issue
of executive privilege.
-The White House is blocking
former President Trump
from playing
the executive privilege card,
and the committee investigating
the January 6th insurrection
says Donald Trump's minions
will not get away
with ignoring the rule of law.
-Okay. Now that's definitely
a middle finger.
So Trump thought he could
just unilaterally
assert executive privilege,
no questions asked.
You're not president
anymore, dude.
That's not how it works.
What's he gonna do next?
Try to book a flight
on Air Force One?
"What do you mean
I can't use the plane anymore?
But what about all those miles
I racked up?
Can I transfer them to JetBlue?
JetBlue.
[ Laughter ]
We love JetBlue,
don't we, folks?"
[ Laughter ]
"JetBlue, the first place
I ever had a Terra chip,
and I remember --"
[ Laughter ]
I remember,
I said to the stewardess,
"There's something wrong
with my chip -- it's red.
I have a red chip."
And she told me, she said to me,
"Sir" -- tears in her eyes --
she said, 'Sir, that's
a seasonal root vegetable.'"
[ Laughter ]
Now, before we dive into
that story any further --
the executive-privilege story --
not the Trump, JetBlue,
Terra chip story.
I think we got all
we're gonna get from that.
[ Laughter ]
And they said we couldn't do
tangents when the audience came.
We're gonna do --
gonna take a few tangents.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I do think it's worth taking
a quick step back to acknowledge
this is our first show with
a live audience in 19 months.
Well, to be fair, we did have
a full audience one night
this summer, but they didn't
laugh at anything,
so we just pretended
they weren't there
and decided to wait a while
before trying again.
It's been a long,
strange trip.
We did a show in my attic,
in my in-laws house,
I befriended Ethan Hawke
and a painting of a sea captain,
I grew my hair out,
and I started dressing
casually -- by choice --
and not,
as "The Daily Mail" reported,
because I had to sell my suits
to cover gambling losses
incurred
when I took me under on the Mets
having one [bleep] season.
[ Laughter ]
Second Mets joke.
First one is in the monologue,
so if you only watch
this online,
you gotta go back
and watch the monologue now.
What's that?
You're not going to?
Because you live in Austria
and you hate the Mets jokes?
Fair enough.
[ Laughter ]
Over the last 19 months,
I became closer with my crew,
who were the only feedback
I had in real time.
Speaking of the crew...
Oh!
Oh, that's very interesting,
because earlier today,
Wally said,
"I bet the first time
you cut to me,
I'll get a round of applause
from the audience and yet --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Doesn't count! Doesn't count!
It doesn't count.
No, no, no!
No, no, no! It doesn't count
'cause he didn't do anything.
[ Laughter ]
You did nothing!
When we cut to him,
you did nothing, and I had to
say it, and then you did it,
so it doesn't count!
[ Laughter ]
Doesn't count, Wally.
-That was too fast of a cut!
-You didn't stipulate
how fast the cut would be!
-This is an outrage!
-Outrage!
Oh, we spent
so much time together,
we finish
each other's sentences.
[ Laughter ]
The point is...
right up until you gave Wally
what he wanted,
I'm thrilled to be back
in front of an audience.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm just hoping my audience
is a little more enthusiastic
than Trump's audience.
The man just refuses to go away.
On Saturday, he went to Iowa
to hold yet another rally
where he repeated
the same deranged lies
about the election that
he's been repeating for months.
And yet even his own crowd
wasn't exactly electrified
by hearing the same old
incoherent nonsense
over and over again.
-You know, I was up by
massive numbers on Election Day.
It was even --
The news was saying, "Wow.
What a big lead
in Pennsylvania."
I love Pennsylvania.
I went to school
in Pennsylvania -- college.
But what a great state
and what great people.
And I was up by so much.
All of a sudden,
the booths close,
the tabulation centers
are closed,
3:00 in the morning.
And shortly thereafter, we tied.
They know they got caught.
All you have to do
is listen to the numbers.
And remember what I said.
Joe Biden has launched a foreign
invasion of his own country.
"Come on in."
He said, "Come in."
This is a, uh --
This is a sick --
This is a sick thing
that's happening to our country.
-Wow. And I was worried about
bringing audiences back.
[ Laughter ]
I never thought I'd say this,
but maybe you should go
into lockdown.
You know, remote shows
might be better for you.
You could borrow my attic.
[ Laughter ]
Although,
if you were in my attic,
I'd never get any sleep.
"Honey, what's that noise?"
"I think he's talking about
how windmills kill birds."
"It's 2:00 --
2:00 in the morning."
"I know, but he had
like 50 Diet Cokes."
[ Laughter ]
"Why did you let him
use our attic?"
"Because he used
to be president!
I'm sorry that
I respect the office!"
Also, I love the cutaways
to sullen Trump fans
just standing there
in silence,
like tourists watching one
of those gold-statue guys
in Times Square.
[ Laughter ]
"So, is he gonna like...
do something?"
[ Laughter ]
And you could tell
Trump was waiting
for a crowd reaction, too.
I mean, look at him.
It's like watching a open-mic
night at the senior center.
"Joe Biden said, 'Come on in.
Come on in.' Am I right?"
[ Laughter ]
"Cyrus knows
what I'm talking about."
[ Laughter ]
"Cyrus?"
"Cyrus."
[ Laughter ]
"Get the paddles.
What else?"
[ Laughter ]
It's been liberating
not having to think or care
about what this lunatic says
or does on a daily basis
for the last few months.
Unfortunately, the GOP
has not felt the same way.
They're still
fully devoted to Trump.
He was joined at his rally
by Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley.
Virtually the entirety
of the Republican Party
remains in thrall to Trump
and committed to the Big Lie
that the election was
somehow stolen from him,
as demonstrated
by this interview,
the number-two House
Republican Steve Scalise did
on Fox News Sunday.
-Do you think the 2020 election
was stolen from Donald Trump?
And continuing
to make that charge.
Not having states
do election reforms
but specifically
making this charge
that the election was stolen.
Do you think that that hurts,
undermines American democracy?
-Well, Chris, I've been very
clear from the beginning.
If you look
at a number of states,
they didn't follow
their state-passed laws.
-The states all certified --
-They didn't follow
those legislative rules.
Right.
But at the end of the day,
are we gonna follow
what the Constitution says?
-Do you think the election
was stolen or not?
I understand you think
there were irregularities
and things that need
to be fixed.
Do you think
the election was stolen?
-And it's not just irregular.
It's states that did not follow
the laws set,
which the Constitution
says they're supposed to follow.
-I like how they say
the word "irregularities"
without actually specifying
what that means.
It's that vague Mafia talk
they've all adopted.
"It's a shame what happened
to your restaurant,
but the boss
got your last payment,
and there was some, uh,
irregularities."
[ Laughter ]
These guys can't actually give
an example of widespread fraud
because there aren't any,
as multiple audits
and roughly 60 court cases,
including with several
Trump-appointed judges, proved.
But all they have are these bat
[bleep] conspiracy theories
promoted by the rotating
cast of weirdos
who inhabit Trump's orbit,
rambling incoherently
about nonsense
like Italian satellites,
hacking voting machines,
or mysterious midnight
election dumps or bamboo
fibers on ballots.
Last week,
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
once again repeated
the insane claim
that dead people
had somehow voted.
-I'll give an example today.
2,650 people
over the age of 100.
Now, you might say,
"Oh, wow. That's --
That could be, that could be.
2,000 of them were over 200.
Wouldn't you like
to live in that state?
Brad, they were
200-and-some years old,
so obviously they
one guy was --
-They were 200 years old?
These people that --
that are voting
are 200 years old?
Of course,
they're obviously not living.
-They're obviously deceased.
But one guy was 850 years old.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
And these are --
And these are facts.
You can get them --
You can get them
from your own state's thing.
-First of all, we know
an 850-year-old who voted, okay?
He was on TV.
[ Laughter ]
That's why -- That's why
Rudy's neck is hunched.
He sleeps in a coffin
that's one size too small.
[ Laughter ]
"I couldn't afford the king-size
'cause I'm paying alimony --
to my cousin.
It's not taboo
amongst vampires."
[ Laughter ]
"The immortal just have
less to choose from."
[ Laughter ]
I also like how Lindell says,
"These are facts,"
but then he can't even name
the database where he got them.
He just says, "You can get them
from your own --
your own state's thing."
[ Laughter ]
"I went online to the thing
and saw all the dead people
who voted
by looking at their birthdays
and counting up the years."
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know, it's nice.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to finally road
test the Lindell
in front of an audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Crowd-pleasing, crowd-pleasing.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
"Did you see my new
lion painting?"
[ Laughter ]
"I hope the lion's not too big."
"I'd hate for the lion painting
to take away from my points."
[ Laughter ]
Lindell, of course,
is being sued for defamation
by the election technology
company Dominion.
And now even a deep-red state
like Idaho
is sending him a bill
for an election audit
because his claims were bogus.
And Lindell's not the only one
facing financial hardship,
thanks to his participation
in the Big Lie.
There's also Rudy Giuliani,
who's reportedly
drowning in legal bills
after Trump refused to pay him.
And now, in a newly
released deposition,
Rudy has explained
why he worked for Trump
without payment.
An attorney in a defamation suit
against Rudy asked Giuliani
whether he was ever paid
to represent the Trump campaign.
Giuliani replied that he was not
paid to represent the campaign
and had been reimbursed
for only his expenses,
according to the transcript.
The attorney then asked Giuliani
why he would represent the Trump
campaign without compensation.
"The president -- the president,
ordered me to do it,"
Giuliani said.
Rudy, that's not how it works.
Your client can't just order you
to do something for free.
You can't let Trump
push you around anymore.
You're a grown man.
You're 850 years old.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And yet, aside from some
potential financial consequences
for weirdos
like Rudy and Lindell,
the co-conspirators who fomented
the January 6th insurrection
and orchestrated
the attempted coup
have largely
escaped accountability,
like Texas Senator Ted Cruz,
who hasn't faced
any consequences for his role
in trying to overturn the
election results on January 6th.
In fact, Cruz is still there
in the Senate, causing chaos.
Just last week, he was whining
that the GOP had done
the bare minimum
to avert economic catastrophe
and mustered just enough votes
to help Democrats
raise the debt ceiling
at the last minute.
Although he chose
a very weird analogy.
-I believe the end result
of this game of chicken
was clear.
Unfortunately, yesterday,
Republicans blinked.
I think that was a mistake.
But sometimes in a poker game,
a bluff wins the pot.
In this case,
to mix my metaphors,
which would make my high school
English teacher very angry,
in the game of chicken,
Chuck Schumer
won this game of chicken.
As two trucks drove towards each
other on a country road,
one or the other was gonna turn,
or you were gonna have
a lot of dead chickens.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- What the hell
are you talking --
[ Laughter ]
You think when two trucks
play chicken on a country road,
they have to be
full of chickens?
That's not -- That's not
why they call it chicken.
"The hardest thing
about the game of chicken
is keeping your resolve.
It's trying to concentrate above
the din of terrified chickens
in the truck,
because, of course,
theirs are the lives at stake."
The Republican Party
has fully embraced
Trumpism and the Big Lie.
They're trying to install
Trump loyalists in key positions
across the country
and passing laws
that would make it easier
to steal the next election.
One of his lawyers wrote an
instruction manual for a coup,
which they could
easily use next time.
These people should
face consequences
for trying
to destroy a democracy
that so far
has stood the test of time.
In fact,
if you ask Mike Lindell,
he'd probably say it's...
-850 years old.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love, We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.